S’il vous plaît.
Jamy, Jamy, Jamy.
Jamy !
Doucement, doucement !
Merci, vraiment,
merci beaucoup
d'être venus
si nombreux.
Cette exposition célèbre
mon million d'abonnés sur YouTube
et aussi 30 ans de transmission
des connaissances.
Je suis vraiment très très honoré
de vous accompagner
depuis toutes ces années.
Monsieur ?
Jamy, cette exposition,
c'est le fruit
de plusieurs
mois de travail.
Est-ce que
vous êtes confiant ?
Effectivement,
ça a été très long.
D'ailleurs,
je tiens à féliciter Maghla,
notre directrice artistique,
qui m'a accompagné
durant toute la mise
en place de ce projet.
Une fan de la première heure ?
Eh bien non, justement,
lorsque je suis allé
vers elle avec ce projet,
elle ne me connaissait
pas du tout.
Cela dit, c'est d'ailleurs
elle qui m'a convaincu d'exposer
mes fameuses lunettes originelles.
Ah oui !
Voilà, je déclare ouverte
l'exposition 1 million d'E…
Jamy !
Les lunettes ont disparu !
Vraiment,
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
pour cette visite privée.
Si vous êtes là,
c'est parce que
vous m'avez beaucoup inspiré
quand je me suis lancé sur les réseaux.
Si j'ai obtenu
ce million d'abonnés,
c'est un peu grâce à vous.
Salut !
Bienvenue à tous,
j'espère que ça va vous plaire.
Non, mais attendez,
c'est un honneur
de découvrir l'expo
avant tout le monde.
Moi, je suis refait, hein !
Non, mais on n'allait
pas manquer ça !
C'est vrai que c'est incroyable !
Même le lieu.
Ouais.
Hé, mais là-bas,
Jamy, je reconnais.
Ah !
La petite télé du camion.
On avait inventé la visio.
Je ne sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte,
mais on pouvait appeler
quelqu'un et on avait
son image en direct.
Bon, évidemment,
c'est moins impressionnant
aujourd'hui.
Et voici l'une des
premières expériences
qui m'a vraiment marqué.
J'étais en seconde.
Elle illustre la température
de fusion de différents métaux.
Et c'est une reproduction
à l'identique.
J'ai d'ailleurs
contacté Noémie Chapo,
sa prof de l'époque,
pour valider chaque détail.
Elle est parfaite.
Presque parfaite !
Maintenant, observez bien :
la température de fusion
du mercure est de -38°C.
Avec la température
qui règne dans cette salle,
le mercure se présente
donc à l'état liquide.
Et si je chauffe légèrement
le gallium…
Incroyable !
J'en étais sûr,
ça devient liquide.
C'est fou !
On continue.
My million
YouTube button.
- Wow !
- Pas ouf.
Ouais, non, pas ouf.
Ben si !
Si, c'est ouf !
Voici Pluton.
C'est une pièce originale.
Je l'ai récupérée
sur ma première maquette
de système solaire.
C'était l'une des 9 planètes.
Mais attends Jamy,
ce n'est pas
pour te contredire, hein,
mais Pluton
ce n'est pas une planète.
C'est vrai !
Depuis 2006,
Pluton n'est plus une planète
du système solaire,
c'est une planète naine.
D'ailleurs…
Excuse-moi Jamy !
L'épisode sur le système solaire
date de 1995
donc à l'époque
Pluton était une planète.
Donc Jamy avait raison.
Bah, je savais.
Ouais.
- Je savais.
- Il savait
Il savait.
Et qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
La machine, là ?
Ça va te plaire.
Tu peux nous prêter une
de tes boucles d'oreilles, Fatou ?
Oui.
En fait,
il s'agit d'une imprimante 3D
expérimentale capable
de scanner un objet
et de le reproduire à partir
de n'importe quel matériau.
On va essayer avec du verre.
Maghla ?
Bien sûr, Jamy.
C'est parti !
C'est un petit bijou
de technologie qui m'a été offert
par un ingénieur qui a pris goût
à la science grâce à...
Grâce à toi, Jamy !
Il est d'une humilité.
Et voilà le résultat.
Wow !
Bluffant, hein ?
Il est maintenant temps
de découvrir la pièce maîtresse
de cette exposition :
mes lunettes originelles.
Je rêve, ce n'est pas possible !
Pincez-moi s'il vous plait
les gars !
Elle pète sa mère, la paire.
Ces lunettes ont pour moi
une valeur sentimentale
inestimable et elles font l'objet
d'un véritable culte
chez mes fans.
Et c'est sa petite première paire.
Moins de 5 à chaque œil,
il a dû la changer
en 2001 car sa myopie
a quelque peu évolué.
C'est juste.
Et grâce à ce dispositif, eh bien,
Maghla s'est assurée
elle-même que mes lunettes
sont en parfaite sécurité.
Grâce à ce dispositif,
je me suis assurée moi-même
que les lunettes seraient
en parfaite sécurité, Jamy.
Et voici la clé
qui permet d'ouvrir
la cage de verre.
Elle est unique et
je la porterai nuit et jour
autour de mon cou.
Et si quelqu'un touche la cage,
l'alarme se déclenche
et Jamy reçoit un SMS.
Impressionnant.
Bon, Jamy,
j'aimerais te faire
une proposition avant
que l'exposition
ouvre au public.
J'aimerais échanger
cette paire de lunette
contre un morceau
de la planète Mars.
Ni plus ni moins.
C'est rarissime.
Énorme.
Bon, c'est très sympa Maxime,
mais non,
ce n'est pas possible, non.
Moi, j'ai un vrai deal.
Ça veut dire, là,
je t'échange ta paire de lunettes
contre ma paire préférée.
Elles sont très belles, mais non.
Non, non, vraiment,
je ne peux pas.
Aucune négociation possible.
Aucune.
La paire reste là.
Bon, écoutez, moi, je file.
Très bonne soirée à vous.
Je pars devant, j'ai un train.
Voilà.
Désolé, merci !
Bah merci beaucoup Jamy !
Je t'en prie, merci à toi.
J'ai oublié mon sac !
Ne te perds pas, hein.
Et surtout,
tu reviens quand tu veux.
La porte est grande ouverte.
Et j'espère que
les gens vont kiffer,
mais y'a pas de doute.
Allez, tchuss !
Ciao.
À la prochaine, les gars !
Salut Fatou !
J'ai hâte.
Ça va être super !
Jamy !
Les lunettes ont disparu !
Mais Jamy,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
On va faire quoi ?
Calmons-nous et réfléchissons.
On est bien d'accord :
hier, quand nous
avons quitté l'exposition,
les lunettes étaient là
et à part le gardien,
personne ne pouvait
rentrer après notre départ.
Hier.
Si, Fatou est partie
chercher son sac
et c'était très suspect, Jamy.
Il faut vraiment
qu'on explore toutes les pistes.
Bah, Amixem.
Quoi, Amixem ?
Il est parti comme un voleur.
C'était suspect aussi.
Comment Amixem aurait
pu voler les lunettes
alors qu'il est parti
avant nous ?
Bah Maxime, tu fais quoi, là ?
Dans cette tenue ?
Alors,
vous allez trouver ça bête,
mais j'ai adoré l'expo d'hier,
j'ai voulu revenir
faire un petit tour.
Oui, c'est ça, menteur !
Tu es venu ici pour voler
les lunettes ?
Ce n'est pas moi !
Jamy, je ne comprends pas.
Il faut interroger les autres.
Bon,
ça fait très longtemps
que je ne l'ai pas utilisée,
mais là,
je crois que le moment est venu.
Salut Jamy !
Ah bah,
ça marche toujours ta visio.
- Impressionnant ?
- Non.
Hé, tout le monde, ça va ou quoi ?
Alors comment ça se passe l'expo,
ça a commencé ?
Attendez,
mais Inox a les lunettes, là ?
Bah oui,
j'ai même dormi avec.
Elles sont top
les lunettes de Jamy.
Jamy, là, actuellement,
je n'y comprends rien.
Pour moi, ils ont tous
les trois volé les lunettes.
Je commence
à comprendre ce qui s'est passé.
Commençons par Fatou.
Elle est bien retournée
dans la salle de l'exposition,
mais elle n'a pas eu le temps
de voler les lunettes.
D'ailleurs,
l'alarme se serait déclenchée
et j'aurais reçu un SMS.
Inoxtag est rentré
chez lui avec des lunettes,
mais c'est le seul à
avoir pris les lunettes
qui lui étaient offertes
au niveau du stand de goodies.
Mais elles sont trop bien !
Bon, par contre,
je vois flou de l'œil gauche.
J'ai vérifié hier,
quand nous avons visité
l'exposition ensemble,
les présentoirs étaient tous complets.
En revanche,
quand nous avons quitté,
Maghla, la salle de l'exposition,
il manquait une paire.
Je regrette d'ailleurs que
chacun n'ait pas pris la sienne.
Désolé, les amis,
de vous avoir dérangé.
- Pas de soucis, à plus !
- Bonne journée à tous !
J'en étais sûre.
En fait, c'est toi
depuis le début, Maxime.
Tu as passé la nuit ici
et tu as eu le temps
de monter un plan
et tu as contourné
la protection de Jamy.
Mais pas du tout.
Alors, c'est vrai qu'à la base,
je devais prendre mon train.
Puis au final,
je me suis dit :
non, on va changer de plan.
Je pense qu'Amixem est sincère,
il a bien passé la nuit
dans l'exposition.
Pour voler les lunettes.
Mais pour y tourner une vidéo.
J'imagine déjà la vignette :
je passe une nuit au musée.
C'est bien ton style, ça.
Mais de toute façon, une nuit
n'aurait pas été suffisante
pour forcer la cage de verre.
Tout est vrai.
Coupable.
Ah !
Mais pas d'avoir volé
les lunettes.
C'est toi, Maghla,
qui les a dérobées.
Alors, là, moi, absolument pas.
Je n'ai pas du tout touché
aux lunettes de la nuit.
Pas cette nuit.
Mais lors des jours précédents.
Non, non, non, non,
non, non, non, non,
jamais.
Absolument pas.
Non.
Oui.
Oui, car c'était le seul
et unique moment
pendant lequel les lunettes
pouvaient être échangées.
Je suis vraiment désolée, Jamy.
Je suis ta plus grande fan, vraiment.
Et tes lunettes, bah,
je les ai toujours voulues, en fait.
Je n'ai pas résisté.
Attendez une minute.
Si les paires ont été échangées,
ça n'explique pas
pourquoi la paire
exposée hier a disparu.
Bien vu.
En fait,
Maghla a fabriqué
une fausse paire de lunette.
Pour cela, elle a utilisé
l'imprimante 3D.
Elle a pris comme modèle
une des paires de lunettes
en plastique au niveau
du stand des goodies,
et comme matériau,
du fer.
Enfin, visiblement,
elle s'est trompée.
L'étiquetage des flacons
a été inversé.
Probablement une erreur
au moment de l'installation
de l'exposition.
C'est ce gallium qu'elle a utilisé
pour fabriquer les lunettes,
croyant utiliser du fer.
Nous ne nous en sommes
pas rendus compte,
tout simplement parce
que cette salle est climatisée.
Le gallium est resté solide alors
que nous savons tous
que sa température
de fusion est de 30°.
Sauf que, Amixem,
tu as passé la nuit ici,
tu as eu froid
et tu as coupé la clim,
ce qui a fait monter
la température.
C'est ce que je me suis dit
en rentrant ce matin
dans cette salle :
il faisait très chaud.
Et voilà, le mal est réparé,
les lunettes peuvent
être exposées.
C'est quoi, ça ?
Ce sont les lunettes
en gallium qui ont fondu
à cause de ton erreur.
Encore une fois, Jamy,
je suis vraiment désolée.
Mais bon,
il est peut-être temps
que je me sépare
de cet objet un peu trop pesant.
Et pourquoi pas les confier
à ma plus grande fan ?
Jamy, je…
Chut.
Allez, il est temps
d'ouvrir l'exposition
1 million d'Epicurieux.
Et dans les autres titres
de l'actualité,
cet immense succès
à l'Opéra de Paris, hier,
pour l'inauguration
de l'exposition consacrée
à Jamy Gourmaud
à l'occasion de ses 30 ans
de vulgarisation scientifique.
Des centaines de visiteurs
se sont pressés pour découvrir
ou redécouvrir le parcours
du journaliste vulgarisateur.
Et point d'orgue de l'exposition,
ses lunettes rondes originelles…
Comme si j'allais exposer
mes vraies lunettes !
Personne ne mettra
jamais la main sur toi.